in movies pretty much every sound effect
and a large chunk of dialogue is made up
in post-production
from footsteps to gunshots to r2d2
but there's more to sound design than
just making believable sounds
humans are surprisingly good at
associating many different sounds with a
particular action on screen
which is why we can think this is
rainfall when it's actually sizzling
bacon
clever designers use this human ability
to add emotion to their mixing instead
of making perfectly realistic sounds
they'll create sounds that seem
close enough to the actual thing to keep
us immersed but that also carried the
emotional feeling of the sound the
result is brain trickery but more
importantly the sound tells us how to
feel to see what i mean let's do some
listening
no i will not be quiet chewbacca why
doesn't anyone listen to me
one movie that effectively deceives our
ears is star wars
and it's not just lying because they
added sound after filming sound designer
ben bird also had to imagine
completely new sounds often times mixing
them from everyday noises like much of
the other sound design around star wars
the sounds are fresh enough to transport
us to a new world but familiar enough so
that they elicit a particular emotional
reaction
the sound of the tie fighters comes from
the roar of elephants
but they also sound very similar to the
german dive bombers from world war
ii
whether or not this connection was
intentional it subtly reminds us they're
the bad guys
here the sound is not only believable
but it also provides the correct
emotional cue but burt does more than
just convey feeling through sound
he uses the sound to tell a story he
accomplishes this feat with perhaps the
most famous sound in movie history
it's worth noting that our first
impression of darth vader doesn't come
from his voice but from his breathing
without that particularly human sound
effect he would only be a faceless
villain in armor but with the addition
of the sound of his breathing
our imaginations run wild how did he get
to be this way
is it assistance or is it enhancement
the mechanical sounds complements his
superhuman strength but it also implies
a human side of him
not only does it sound like life support
but it quickens when he duels
showing he's not invincible his
ambiguous sound design complements his
mystery as a villain as well as his
character arc
right from the beginning we get a subtle
indication of a flawed and potentially
redeemable character before
bird aliens tended to have cold and flat
sound design with generic shrieks
he added storytelling into his made up
sounds so that chewbacca can sound like
an alien creature while also having a
broad and
earthly emotional range
all right don't lose your temper and he
adds that emotion to all his sounds
not just with aliens if you listen to
explosions off on the news things
recorded in actual warfare sometimes it
doesn't seem
to have quite the body and the tone
range that you are used to hearing in
motion pictures
for the best explosion sounds burt
actually had to mix them from missiles
rockets and tanks
even with an actual sound available he
fabricated his own to capture the
emotion behind the sound
[Music]
filmmakers regularly add style to
pre-existing noises for emotional effect
in sergio leone movies the gunshot noise
is actually the sound of a cannon firing
this choice perfectly embodies the
exaggerated style of spaghetti westerns
giving gunshots more weight in epic
showdowns where every bullet counts
the sound wouldn't fit in early john
wayne westerns where gunfire is frequent
and less consequential a gunshot can
capture the overall feeling of an action
movie the sound designers for no country
for old men specifically said they
weren't looking to create something
realistic out of their gunshots but
something menacing
[Music]
they describe the silencer noise as
homemade and the sound
suits anton perfectly even though he
acts so cold and evil his murders sound
intimate and personal as he invades
people's homes and workplaces
this mixing of the intimate and the
calculated creates a conflicting and
disturbing atmosphere around our villain
when it comes to anton you're the most
vulnerable where you're the most
comfortable when listening to a gun in a
movie the sound gives you a better idea
of the kind of movie you're watching
than the actual sound of a gunshot which
is part of the reason why this
sounds a lot different than this
to capture the feeling of chaotic combat
in saving private ryan sound designer
gary ridestrom placed heavy emphasis on
bullets moving
instead of just gunshots
the normandy scene has different sounds
for bullets hitting the ocean
the beach or helmets and this level of
detail helps the scene stand out from
other war movies where all the bullets
tend to feel the
same where the hell are they i can't say
nothing
one scene in saving private ryan opens
with the beginning of rainfall as it
rains harder we start to hear gunfire
and for a few seconds
it's impossible to differentiate the
sound of rain from the sound of bullets
here we are literally hearing gunfire
rain down on us it's a clever auditory
trick but more importantly it places us
in the same emotional space as the
characters on screen the entire movie is
an incredible example of subjective
sound
in the same way that a director of
photography chooses what to focus on the
sound designer in saving private ryan
chooses what the audience should hear
at the beginning of the sniper standoff
you can hear people in the town
artillery and soldiers talking once we
see the two snipers looking from their
scopes we only hear water dripping we
cut from the german drips on the window
to the metallic drips from the american
the isolation of a specific sound
differentiates the two spaces and puts
us in the sniper's head tuning out our
surroundings to land an important shot
[Music]
sound can be a completely subjective
experience depending on the moment
in raging bull jake appears to hear
everything vicky says to tommy even
though she's across the room the
dialogue is also out of sync with their
lips
implying that jake is imagining it all
in the movie jake asserts his manhood to
himself
and the public by beating up other men
he takes pride in the praise he gets
while fighting and sound designer frank
warner emphasizes the scrutiny he feels
while in the ring as he fights we always
hear faceless commentators judging his
every move and the flash bulbs from the
cameras constantly watch him
increasing in intensity and frequency
during dramatic moments
and soon that aggression and scrutiny
shows itself outside of the ring while
jake watches tommy and vicky we hear the
same flashbulb noise over each cut
even though there aren't any cameras
there in this moment he feels the sounds
of the ring the sounds of others
watching and judging him but his
opponent is now
a man flirting with his wife through the
sound design we can hear how jake now
sees the real world as a boxing ring
and everyone in it as potential
opponents these sound choices foreshadow
the eventual fight between joey and jake
where we hear the same animal noises we
previously only heard in the ring
[Music]
in this movie the flash bulbs are a dark
mechanical reminder of jake's broken
psyche
his obsession with asserting masculinity
ruined his life and he ends up
completely alone because of it
and at the end when he's lost everything
it's still the only thing he has
i sounded those flash bulbs was more
than just a bulb
there were five or six sounds and
they're working for each one of those
flashes
marty asked me how i did that i said i
won't tell you
and he got a little upset and i said if
i told you all the magic will be gone
new card what do you think it's fun to
know the creative ways foley artists
make their sounds but the real
innovation comes from the emotional
effect of those sounds in american
psycho the card holder opening is the
sound of a sword coming out of a sheath
it's the perfect sound for an already
ridiculous scene where the comparison of
business cards feels like a duel to the
death
through exaggerating noise we enhance
the dramatic moment
and the same goes for comedic sound as
the sound designer for naked gun said
it's funnier to not use reality but i
think my favorite sound design choices
are when filmmakers add noise where
there shouldn't be any in the first
place
there are girls watching it's a perfect
way to give
weight to movement whether it's for
laughs or intensity
call me some of the most imaginative
sound design comes from the wachowskis
where they'll even add sound to the
movement
of the camera
their film the matrix is the perfect
case study to see how far
sound can go designer dane davis said he
wanted the sound design to evolve during
the movie
becoming increasingly stylistic and
powerful the first fight with trinity
broke some rules but the combat sounds
relatively realistic
other than trinity's questionable feats
the opening fight has sound design that
could have been in a typical action
movie but with each fight davis
recreated his noises from scratch
notice how the hits have a little bit
more weight to them in the construct
progressively more stylized sounds of
the matrix contrast to the scenes in
reality where the sound design is always
grounded and heavy by the lobby scene
the sound feels far removed from reality
davis slowed down and sped up the sound
effects to show how neo bends his own
reality
at some moments we only hear the bullets
moving other times only the sound of
bullets hitting stone
in this scene the matrix pushes the
envelope for what's possible in sound
design
and it's the movie's gradual progression
to this point that helps make the scene
believable davis knew how far he could
push the sound design he had an idea to
make the simulations reuse
sound effects to make it feel fake like
having all the footsteps sound the same
or make some sounds loop in the
background but they ran into the problem
that limitations of the matrix might
feel like limitations of the filmmakers
as in bad filmmaking so he knew when he
could change the rules and when he
couldn't but in many ways
the rules of the matrix are a lot like
the rules of sound design
some of them can be bent others can be
broken
you hear that yeah that is the sound of
a thousand terrible things heading this
way
i think ben bert sums up sound design
best when describing making a space
shuttle sound by recording the los
angeles freeway i was miking at various
distances but the sound still didn't
sound
full enough i took that sound ran it
through a subwoofer took
all the highs out of it and when i added
it to the production sound
somehow it sounded more like the real
thing than the real thing
when it comes to sound design lying gets
us closer to the truth and depending on
the movie what that sound needs to
feel like could be completely different
a filmmaker's job
first and foremost is to capture the
emotion of a story and in many cases
actual realism comes second so the next
time you watch a movie don't just pay
attention to the sound
pay attention to what that sound is
trying to say because you never quite sh
do you hear that it's the winds of
change
you hear it you hear the winds what a
creep
one of these days i am really gonna let
you teach that guy a lesson
many sound designers are secret about
their craft frank warner famously
destroyed all his sounds after each
movie and george lucas owns a secluded
ranch in california where his production
companies gather their sounds thankfully
modern technology means you don't have
to go to such extremes to protect your
work with the right tools you can stay
completely secure while online for a
product that's easy to use and has
all the features i need i use dashlane
with dashlane you can manage your
passwords generate new secure passwords
and have your own vpn i have all my
sensitive information and passwords
stored through my dashlane account so
that i stay safe while i'm online you
can try out the basic free version
before deciding to purchase
all you have to do is download it and
you won't have to worry about online
security issues ever again
go to the link in the description to try
dashlane premium free for 30 days and if
you like it the first 200 people can use
the code now you see it to get 10
off dashlane premium at checkout thank
you dashlane for sponsoring this video
and thank you to my patreon supporters
who all got early access to this video
before the general public
thanks for watching